ha ha, you tell 'em morty. jeez, you guys
don't have to be dicks about it alright
yeah, neither did the guys before us but you
know what they were merry Christmas yeah
those actresses future b*tches. So mean,
guys are mean... Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is going to be my Rick and
Morty season four episode of five video
the mid-season finale I know you'll have
a lot of questions about what's going on
with the rest of the episodes for season
four so I'll address that at the end of
the video too if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I will be doing bonus videos
during the break too there is a new
round of that merch giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite time travel Rick
and Morty moment from the episode that's
right everybody reach for your box of
time-travel stuff on the garage shelf
because they finally did a big time
travel story the thing that they said
they were never going to do so careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet will do top 10 and
Easter eggs as we go along there were a
lot of callbacks to earlier episodes
they've got to that point where there's
enough Rick and Morty episodes in the
past couple of years that they can start
referencing all the stuff that they did
in previous episodes without it feeling
too recent so starting with number 10
the title of the episode rattle star
Rick lacta
a reference to Battlestar Galactica we
learn during the cold open scene that
Rick has a bunch of different methods
for avoiding having to stop to go to the
bathroom every couple of hours he's got
a pee jug he's also got a centipede you
can swallow that we'll take care of it
which we later learned that he's
actually using during the course of this
episode and there's another promo where
they reference summer having go to the
bathroom and Rick going to find her one
and morty revealing that rick put a
catheter in him at some point
technically i don't think that that's
canon because this version of morty
clearly doesn't have a catheter put in
him but mrs. received rick really hates
stopping to go to the bathroom while on
adventures number nine jerry's storyline
he's incompetent through most of the
episode which is pretty standard jerry
but his whole mission is to put up
Christmas lights they kind of gave this
episode of Christmas theme it's
Christmas in real life when they're
releasing the episode they obviously
planned it this way there's also a
Christmas card at the end of the episode
with a bunch of snake hisses on it this
is one of the many episodes when Rick
refers to himself as a god he says he
earned his status as a God rather than
being born into it remember Christmas
theme talking about Jesus Christ the
Christian God he claims his idea for
fixing jerry's situation is way more
complex than just walking on water you
notice though that despite the help
despite all the trouble that Rick went
through in all the trouble that Jerry
went through to put the Christmas lights
up he still does a really crappy job of
it like he winds it around this
satellite dish this just feels like a
disaster waiting to happen even after he
completes the task number eight Morty
versus the space snake so they get a
flat tire and this is obviously just a
big joke about anything being able to
happen in space the writer said
literally they just wanted to have some
fun with the idea that anything could
happen in space we find out about more
secret functions that Rick ship has oh I
have a simulation device that simulates
flat tire experiences on earth he also
has the Christopher Walken message this
Ellen oh that's just terrible but we
later learn that Christopher Walken also
gave him a special device for pausing
people which seemed like a reference to
that Adam Sandler movie click where he
gets the remote controlled that can
affect the flow of time but Rick makes a
whole bunch of pop-culture movie
references when he goes to fix the flat
tire the bit about the guys spinning
away when two of them leave the ship is
basically every space-based movie and TV
show there's always some point in a
space based TV show where one dude goes flying off because of some accident we
learned he's got some spacesuits that
work a lot like Iron Man's nano BOTS
armor from Avengers infinity war and
Avengers end games they just form around
him when he needs them they start the
running gag about Morty not staying
inside the ship when Rick tells him like
he yells at him stay inside the ship I
believe he tells him two more times
which feels kind of like a callback to
the joke from season 3 episode 1 where
Rick says comedy comes in threes in this
episode he tells Morty to stay inside
the ship three times the third time is
when he gets ready to punch him in that
christmas-card scene at the end of the
episode he also makes a big joke about
Saturday Night Live it's so utterly
specific in their take down that I'm
assuming Dan Harmon wrote this bit and
he just doesn't like Saturday Night Live
that much because it sucks all the air
out of you making you float around it
like a flash mummified corpse which is
also what space wants Rick's joke about
everything being in space is also very
true because even though we for example
are standing on planet Earth earth is a
planet in space meaning that we are
technically in space number seven
they go to the snake planet so obviously
this is kind of a silly idea the whole
joke about the snake planet there's 19
billion
snakes made up of 10,000 different
countries on the brink of global war
because of racism it's just a darkest
timeline parody of Earth right now taken
to the extreme some of the background
details of their snake culture are
hilarious the way they committed to this
bit like you have snake nuclear warheads
but the missiles are all curvy snake
bodies they make a joke about Buzz
Aldrin when Morty says what's his name
buzz aspirin and Rick also gets it wrong
correcting him to buzz advil both types
of pain medication it seems like snake
jazz is now the new human music of Rick
and Morty when Rick mentions Jeff
Foxworthy talking about the snake
culture it's him referencing Jeff
Foxworthy's you might be a redneck joke
for Matt that he's so famous for over in
Jerry land while he's busy getting
himself into trouble he makes a white
men can't jump reference that's an
actual movie with Woody Harrelson and
Wesley Snipes this is also one of their
first celebrity cameos this guy is
voiced by Phil Lamarr he does a whole
bunch of different animated series they
also make another fascist joke
during this storyline but there's a
couple other during the episode so many
references this season on Rick
Oh Morty between this in season four
episode one number six more to guess his
replacement snake you notice when they
actually land in the garage and Rick's
like peace I'm out of here they linger
on the box of time-travel stuff in the
background
remember how they said early on I think
it was back during season one when they
were promoting the show they said that
that was there because they never ever
wanted to use time travel in an episode
Rick and Morty was all about different
realities not about time travel but
here's a drinking game for you take a
drink every time Morty gets bitten by a
snake in this episode but number five
the interdimensional Cable Easter egg
when he sneaks past Rick to steal a
spaceship you hear that Rick is actually
watching or fell asleep watching the
same plum bus ad from interdimensional
cable - which i think is another clue
that they are planning on doing
interdimensional cable 3 later this
season but number 4 welcome to the
planet of the snakes they do a bit of a
Planet of the Apes parody where the
snakes have evolved to human culture
they're all wearing clothes like humans
which seems kind of weird
you see snake ships with little fangs
built onto the front of them like are
the ships going to bite people what's going
on here I loved how much they committed
to this bit you either love this or you
hated it but I thought that it actually
worked really well this is one of my
favorite episodes of the season one of
the things that also made it work so
well
there were no subtitles during the snake
hissing scenes when they were talking to
each other like you just see snakes
hissing gibberish at each other also
made the joke just a little bit funnier
snakes flying jets reporter snakes
snakes wearing lipstick snakes with
newspapers and a complex written snake
language but the whole reason for the
Terminator snakes during the episode is
because they translate this earth snakes
language in the snake tells them about
how all the snakes are kept in captivity
humans are monsters they treat us like
animals during this part of the episode
they also imply that Ric trapped Jerry
in a painting at one point that's a
reference to an episode of are you
afraid of the dark where there's a witch
that traps people inside paintings but
number 3 terminator snakes so the
Terminator plot starts with them doing a
parody of each different Terminator
movie I think they really mostly focused
on Terminator 1 and Terminator 2 but
when the first Terminator snake comes
and interrupts Marty while he's busy
jacking it to his phone
that's them doing the first Terminator
movie because you see this version of
Kyle Reese snake wearing the same outfit
as he did during the first Terminator
movie morty becomes their version of
John Connor you see them do the
Terminator 2 intro scene it's literally
the scene from the beginning of
Terminator 2 when the human looking
Terminator snake hybrid tries to save
them in the garage that's also them
doing Terminator 2 with the
Schwarzenegger good a terminator coming
back in time they named their version of
Skynet cerpac or and then when you get
that female snake voiceover that's just
the Sarah Connor voiceover from the
beginning of Terminator 2 when Rick and
Morty travel to the snake planet they do
a Robocop parody this is meant to be
there Edie
2:09 from that first Robocop movie
things really start to go out of control
with the Terminator competing timelines
and they have their Sarah Connor moment
where the snake says this does not make
sense number two Rick gives the
snakes time travel so again just another
thing that Rick and Morty said it was
never going to do hammering home the
time-travel plot rick complains about
having to learn snake math a lot of
these bits here they then pay off at the
end of the episode because then the
future versions of rick and morty come
back to help them by giving them the
snake costume so they can go back to the
80s morty says he wonders how he got a
black eye they answered that in the
post-credits scene with this version of
rick punching him in the face saying
stay in the ship when they go back to
1985 snake MIT you see a snake back to
the future post
in the background Rick breaks the fourth
wall way says we're removing ourselves
from this sloppy story that's the
writers calling out the inherent flaws
in all time travel movies and TV shows
just the fact that none of the plots
ever makes sense when the snakes get
time travel early they start messing
around by saving snake Abraham Lincoln
from being assassinated but the twist is
they then bring it back around to
another joke in present-day
now there's a statue
of Abraham Lincoln as a fascist was I
feel like as a call back to a bird alpha
Winkler so pour one out for him
technically I think he's still alive
though the chainsaw gun seems like one
of the animators doing a Gears of War
reference that they then later bring
back when they go back to kill snake
Hitler things go completely off the
rails but it's all part of Rick's plan
to make them go stupid way faster so
that they get on the radar of the
testicle fourth-dimensional aliens and
they come to fix things summer also
reminds us about how freaky and DTF she
is revealing she's into choking no
choking without my consent they bring
back the fourth dimensional beings from
ricky'll and time played by key and
Peele but it's only key this time and
the other one is played by Eddie
Pepitone just another celebrity comedian
they fix things by beating up the
caveman snake so that they never evolved
past a certain point the snakes in
present-day eat their own tails
disappearing into the timeline paying
off
Rick's reference earlier in the episode
saying that he wanted this plot to eat
its own tail he breaks the fourth wall
again when he says you can only get so
much curvature out of a time travel
story like this it's the same type of
reference as when they did the squirrels
bit about having to pack up and move to
another reality I told you Morty we
could only do this a couple more times
because that's how long they have before
the joke stops being funny
they bring back Morty's adventure card
Rick tears it up because it's the final
adventure on this card because of that
Morty can't go to boob world r.i.p boob
world even summer doesn't seem that
impressed by it it kind of makes it
sound like she's been there before like
uh you know maybe we'll go to boob world
again sometime whatever Jerry finishes
the Christmas lights they again
reference how incompetent he is but he
and Rick sort of find their compromise
again they've kind of done that several
times in the past where they're both at
each other's throats for most of the
episode but then by the end they find
some common ground they pay off the Rick and Morty time travel bit from earlier
when it's revealed that these versions
have to become those versions and make
the suits that they would
later give to their past selves earlier
in the episode that's the writers
attempt to logically close their own
time travel loop in the episode but
number one of course the
post-credits scene where Rick learns
snake math and Morty sews the snake
costumes than paying off the bit about
Morty having a black eye when Rick
punches him in the face stay inside the
ship if there any big Easter eggs in the
episode that you spotted that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments and I will do
another Rick and Morty bonus video this
week talking about what's going on with
the second half of season 4 episodes 6
through 10 because there are 10 episodes
total during Rick and Morty season 4
this is just the first half of the
season but they are going on break so
there is no new Rick and Morty episode
next week or anything like that my
non-spoilery Star Wars rise of Skywalker
review will post on Wednesday that's
also when I'll be posting my Mandalorian
episode 7 video because that's coming
early because rise of Skywalker is
coming out later this week leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below
and everybody click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 4 video and click
here for my new Mandalorian episode 6
video thank you so much for watching
happy holidays everyone I'll see you
guys tonight!